c'est un résultat solide mais un
résultat qui doit être confirmée nous
devons arracher la majorité absolue
dimanche prochain dimanche aucune voix
ne doit manquer à la république
dimanche je compte sur vous pour doter
notre pays d'une majorité solide
bizarrement le monarque voyons c'est
s'étaient enfuis et nous et c'est très
étonnant
la mise en scène fait rudement penser à
ça non moi je vais vous dire j'ai un
président américain ça non mais surtout
un avion derrière mais on a vraiment
l'impression que pour le coup chez
emmanuel macron actuellement dans la
macro nous disons il ya plus de pilote
dans l'avion il n'y a pas un seul
responsable de la république en marche
qui dit la même chose
là un seul il y en a pas un qui dit la
même chose
donc j'ai été amené à dire ce matin mais
est ce qu'il ya un pilote dans l'avion
la chaleur s'installe c'est même une
canicule qui devrait toucher certains
départements en raison non pas d'une
vague mais d'une plume de chaleur elle
transporte un air chaud et sec venu
d'afrique conséquence le mercure va
grimper sur tout le pays jusqu'en fin de
semaine les français sont très
impatients de voir comment vous allez
vous comporter dans l'opposition c'est
le signal qui dans ce dossier
et vous aurez tous
nos opposants le gouvernement appelle à
la vigilance et déploie des mesures
d'accélération de la préparation aux
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
je dis aux français ce matin attention
au rôle de faux opposants qui est en
train de vie de monsieur mélenchon donc
fin de la fab il ne peut évidemment pas
être premier ministre le store de jeu
planchon contrairement à ce que
j'entends depuis avant-hier il est
décevant il a rassemblé des carottes et
des navets des gens qui sont d'accord
sur rien et malgré ça il n'améliore pas
le score de la gauche par rapport à 2010
c'est bono maintenant qu'il est élu
triomphalement comme vous le dites au
premier tour chantera ses
jambières
il fait chaud dans le gers aujourd'hui
fait très chaud ici à auch
m jean lui
danièle obono chant souvent la
marseillaise la france insoumise ce sont
des gens qui défendent le burqini c'est
des députés comme madame au bono qui
revendique le droit de pouvoir dire
nique la france ce sont des députés
comme l'âme garrido qui considère qu'il
faut se réconcilier avec les terroristes
ça veut dire juste si je peux terminer
ma phrase que la ligne est très claire
pas une seule voie au rassemblement
national quand moi je vois des ministres
comme olivier grégoire ou comme clément
bonne appelé à voter appelé à retirer
leur candidat comme c'est le cas en
lot-et-garonne où la république en
marche retire l'un de ses candidats pour
appeler à voter pour l'extrême gauche
mais quel jeu du mail révèle le
caractère absolument écoeurantes des
magouilles d'appareils entre l air air
lr unis baisse des bourses européennes
ont fortement décroché hier mais aussi
aujourd'hui à paris le cac 40 vient de
passer sous les 6000 points et a perdu 8
% en cinq séances en cause le
propriétaire du site pornographique
jackie et michel est en garde à vue sa
femme également un cinquantième de quoi
sont-ils soupçonné de faits graves
écoutez plutôt complicité de viol
complicité de proxénétisme complicité de
traite des êtres humains alors pour bien
comprendre les investisseurs redoutent
une forte augmentation des taux
d'intérêt par la réserve fédérale
américaine
cela pourrait provoquer une récession
qui annulerait alors la reprise de la
croissance images qui nous arrive du
célèbre parc national de yellowstone aux
états unis une maison qui s'effondre
emporté par un torrent de boue des
intempéries provoquent des inondations
impressionnante et c'est dans ce cadre
donc ce matin michel piron le patron du
site son épouse ainsi que cinq autres
personnes ont été placées en garde à vue